from The Daily Mail San Francisco D.A
releases graphic footage of Walgreens
security guard shooting dead transgender
shoplifter and says she won't charge him
because he was in Mortal Danger
let me just tell you I'm not going to
show the video I don't like showing that
stuff the security guard walks calmly up
to the to the shoplifter who's backing
away with their hands up and then just
pulls out his gun and shoots the person
there's something really interesting
about the political dynamics of how they
handle this
the security guard was black the Tran
the shoplifter was black and the da is
like nah we're not going to do any
charges I don't know if race played a
role because the shoplifter was trans so
you I don't know how the hierarchy of
Oppression matters here but apparently
not enough to Warrant criminal charges
after shooting this person but Daniel
penny who was protecting himself and
others
and not the two other people
who assisted in this in subduing Daniel
penny I'm sorry uh Jordan Neely three
people subdued Jordan Neely only penny
is being criminally charged in this
story from from San Francisco no charges
I wonder if we will hear anything from
ocasio-cortez or any other Democrat
about this well Curtis Sliwa of New York
he he ran for uh governor of New York I
believe or mayor of New York uh he made
a great point on Hannity recently where
the the penny uh case is it has all the
characteristics of a combustible story
for the media it is a white on black
self-defense case and of course this
case is not going to be any of that
criteria that the media can eat up or or
you know weaponize to their advantage so
of course this this is going to go yeah
yes it's going to be go right into right
under the covers I mean when I think it
was an Asian woman who was murdered when
the in New York when the homeless black
man shoved her in front of an oncoming
train I believe she was Asian media
didn't didn't care AOC didn't care no
Democrat outrage 25th attempted murder
uh or attempted murder and the second
actual murder of shoving someone in
front of a train and they don't say a
single word
25th what do you mean 25 times in 2022
in one year
people were shoved in front of oncoming
trains two of them died in New York in
New York alone alone I've not heard of
this 25 people have died
25 died to the 25th when you live in New
York and you hear the stories they're
like these crazy people are will try to
murder you and then you're on a train
sealed in and the guy outrights issues
death threats which he did according to
Witnesses
you're thinking we we better subdue this
guy and then Penny and two other men
said his behavior was so alarming he
must be subdued and then after they did
they put him in the recovery position to
save his life and Neely was still moving
around
and then when they brought him to the
hospital he ended up dying
what are you supposed to do if you live
in New York you keep hearing these
stories about these murders or attempted
murders just just be like better not
make eye contact with this crazy person
unless he tried to kill me
that's New York City I think that's the
I mean that's kind of the general kind
of operating system that people go on in
New York right you don't look at the
homeless people and you just don't look
them in the eye hope that they don't
notice you and just kind of head down
look in your phone and you make they
decide not to follow you I tell you man
working for these non-profits the number
one thing everybody knows when you see
one of those guys on the street the
clipboard no eye contact the moment you
make eye contact they got you you're
walking down the street you see that
Greenpeace guy if you look him in the
eyes they're gonna walk right up to you
and you're like ah crap now imagine that
guy with the the clipboard was actually
a crazy person with a Cleaver and then
imagine what your life is going to be
like but ultimately it comes down to
this genuine question for everybody
listening live or whatever put a comment
in
and I think everybody knows the answer
everyone's got a strong answer why
Democrats don't address
the crime as bad as it is and only in
instances like Daniel Penny because
Society has already victimized the
person that is committing the crime that
uh the Michael Jackson and uh
impersonator he was homeless he was had
mental illness he was a he had been
victimized by Society multiple times
Society didn't provide him the health
care he needed the society didn't
provide him the housing that he needed
Society didn't provide him with food
with the with the things that he needs
to sustain stuff so Society has
victimized this man already when he is
acting out it is immoral to allow a
person that has an able is able-bodied
does not have any kind of uh mental
illness
to put their hands on him and then kill
him that is absolutely atrocious from
the perspective of the left that is the
exact logic that they use it is
unacceptable that that man is victimized
over and over and over he's victimized
by Society he's victimized by his mental
health condition and then to top it all
off he is murdered by a privileged man
that's exact that is the exact thought
process that's exactly why they don't
want him to be set free it is absolutely
disgusting but that's what the lot
that's how the logic goes you think they
want Daniel Penny to pay the price for
everything Jordan Neely went through
well it to some degree but it's it's not
that they want him to pay the price for
all the stuff that Jordan went through
it's just that Jordan had suffered
enough so by defending by defending
everyone's on the on the train and
ending his life is adding only more
victimization to him it wasn't a good
thing that Daniel tried to protect
people it was a bad thing because it
ended with his with with Jordan's death
that's the logic of the of the left and
and it may not make sense to you but you
they're not liberals and so they don't
have the same philosophy that liberals
do and I agree except for when it comes
to like AOC I think she's just sitting
there and she's like she wakes up looks
through her phone and then she goes is
what's popular today and then her
boyfriend's like oh there was like a
homeless guy who tried to kill some
people and then he died she's like and
and we're supporting him right yeah oh
okay that's because she's a communist
apparatchik that's why she's just like
whatever gets me followers yeah
and then people suffer because of it I
think she's evil maliciously I do think
I think she is too because the fact that
they hide the fact that they're
Communists her comms director or
whatever just recently yeah and joined
the DSA or whatever the DSA is openly
Marxist we have actual Communists in our
government now and people think that I'm
crazy for saying that there's Communists
like and you just have to listen to them
do you think Democrats avoid talking
about crime in cities because they don't
want to deter people from going there do
you think this is the last thing that
we'll be able to uh they can hold on to
like I think they're trying to make
people forget about defunding the police
I mean the summer of love the summer the
2020 Summer of Love that was that was
inspired by the Democrat rhetoric do you
feel like we're going into another one
with this I mean I think they're trying
to excite it at every turn the protest
in New York were pretty serious I mean
they stopped trains they walked across
the bridge they I mean they were
disruptive to transportation in a major
city I think it's the goal of the
Democrats for at every turn when a
situation like this that they can
weaponize comes up they want people to
go and Riot I hope this the situation
with Penny can open the door to some
major Statewide precedent or maybe even
Federal which I doubt Federal but maybe
Statewide about self-defense maybe this
fight can turn into something some
something more than just one guy being
found not guilty or whatever maybe
they'll actually say like here are the
parameters by which you are able to
defend yourself and charges cannot be
brought because there's no grand jury
indictment against Daniel Penny the D.A
just said oh they're protesting arrest
them yeah we can't stand for that so so
hopefully we get more out of this right
initially they brought him in talked to
him released him and then there like
just kidding we're gonna charge you so
he turned himself in there needs to be
pressure put on district attorneys that
would behave in this way most people
that that vote for DA's and stuff like
that if you're most of the time they're
they're activists and they are
actively seeking left-leaning policies
and these left-leaning policies things
like you know uh getting allowing
violent offenders to get bail or no cash
bail and stuff they have consequences in
the real world now this poor guy that
the homeless guy like he had a he had
the deck stacked against him I don't
want to come off like I'm I'm ignoring
that fact because the guy did had you
know everything going wrong for the poor
guy but like you can't allow violent
offenders to just be on the street and
this guy like Jordan had committed
crimes he was a violent offender he had
yeah and he just offered a treatment
program and he left the treatment
program instead of instead of being
incarcerated he was offered essentially
rehab too many people on the left think
that the lack of housing is why we have
homeless people and that is not the case
homeless people choose to do things that
makes them remain homeless some of them
actually choose to be homeless but some
of of them are on on drugs and if you're
on drugs and you can't pay your rent
that's and you don't quit the drugs
that's cheap yeah that choosing to be
homeless because you're choosing to do
drugs this is another reason why George
Soros has been targeting these da races
across the country because a lot of the
times I think people want the Congress
to you know I I see the frustration when
they're saying why aren't people being
prosecuted or wiring their charges being
brought against these folks when there
are so many congressional investigations
but the Congress can only do so much
they're not another they're not the law
enforcement wing of of the body of
government and so if you attack the DA's
you can win a lot of the culture War
issues if uh if a case like Jordan
Neely's comes across your desk
I wouldn't be surprised if we see a more
serious effort to challenge or recall
brag somehow because he is just
really making everyone mad here except
for some people I guess who who think
he's doing a great job we got a Super
Chat we normally say these for the end
but it's too good it must be in this
segment James Wallace says they have to
blame Penny because if it's not his
fault then it's theirs it's true that's
a really really good point if Penny
isn't the bad guy then how did something
like this happen if penny is the victim
then the problem is their failed
policies releasing dangerous unwell
individuals under the streets and Jordan
Neely had been in foster care as a kid I
mean they had many times many chances to
intervene if the state is the answer
they actually had a lot of contact with
this person and they were never able to
help him effectively is what is what
this would mean right and I think there
is some sort of inability to admit that
right because if if they have had
contact with someone since they were a
at least as far as I know a young
teenager all the way to now and they
could not help this person in fact this
person continued to commit violent acts
against other citizens in jurisdictions
that had their the policies that they
prefer it's not like New York has a hard
time taxing or finding a tax base uh or
coming up with people that will vote for
policies that provide for the homeless
and provide for the people that need
mental thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time